here are the latest calls between former
President Obama and president Trump hey
it's been a while yeah I was pretty
happy about that what do you what I've
been up to
I'm well aware of what you I Bob Syria
and s Connecticut everybody loved it I'm
not so sure about that serious job Isis
job it's so simple why did you do the
Bob thing because it's not that simple
Donald yeah it is I'm gonna go stop
North Korea and California tout by what
should I do about the do it Korea thing
you have to tread lightly Kim Jong hoon
is a reckless ignorant maniac capable of
destroying his entire country oughta win
exactly I'm suing him for copyright
infringement effects hi hello hey bear
mother of all Bob did you see it yeah
I'm not sure what that accomplished it
was an incredible show of course sent a
message not sure about that but you know
what my rack now that I think about it
what that I drop the mother of all Bob's
now all the other Bob's are without a
mother
they're all gone facedown little Bobby
[Applause]
are you jealous why would I be I could
throw the White House got Rick the
Senate there's a brave good you gotta be
jealous but you don't have control of
your temper doctrine shut up you can't
control your impulses I'll kill you if
it's a control your bowel
[Music]
[Applause]
you